نحن نتواجد الان هنا في ابراج الشيخ زايد
هنا في بيت لاهيه شمال قطاع غزه هذه
الابراج الي دمرها الاحتلال بالكامل اكثر
من 60 برج تم تدميره بالكامل كانت هذه
الابراج تاوي الاف السكان هنا لكن
الاحتلال قام بقصفها وايضا قام بقصف اكبر
مسجد هنا في شمال قطاع غزه مسجد الشيخ
زايد واخرجه عن الخدمه كما نشاهد حجم هذا
الدمار في هذه المنطقه بعد تراجع قوات
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال من هذا المكان
هنا كانت تتمركز قوات الاحتلال في هذه
الساحه ايضا هنا الاهالي عادوا الى هذه
المناطق هنا في بيت لاهيه للبحث عن
منازلهم
ومحاوله البحث عن سبل للحياه من جديد بعد
تدمير هذه الابراج وللاستمرار ايضا في
الحياه مدينه الشيخ زايد لط تح للسكن
لانها كلياتها مدمره 70 بورد لا ماوى لاحد
فيهم جميع الشقق مدمره جميع ال جميع
المرافق الحيويه فيها مدمره يعني لا ميه
لا كهرب لا نت لا دور فيش اي مقومات
للحياه العوده هلقيت احنا صرنا مجبرين
للعوده احنا صرنا مجبرين لانه احنا قاعدين
في خيم في خيم في المدارس الوكاله احنا
الان رجعنا هنا انا والجماعه هذول رجعنا
هنا اخوالي يمكن اكثر من 60 70 عئله رجعوا
اكثر من 60 70 عئله رجعوا حتى لو في غرفه
واحده في بيته صالحه للسكن قعد فيها اه يا
عمي افضل ما تضلك قاعد في الشارع احنا
مجبرين خلق سبل الحياه الان لانه احنا
الان بعد ما انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
المنطقه من هنا من شمال من بيت لاهيه
والشيخ زايد وتل الزعتر والعزبه والمناطق
اللي انسحب منها السكان بدات تعود كل واحد
له بيت اد يدور على بيته بده يرجع ل لانه
كل واحد في الاول وفي الاخر بيته هو الوطن
الوطن هو بيته فكيات احنا الان واقفين
يعني كلياتنا بنسعى كل واحد يرتب بيته
ويرجع لبيته هي اطلع يعني هي وراك اطلع
على الناس كيف كل واحد جاي بعته وجاي هي
كل واحد جاي يدور على ماوى كل واحد جاي
يدور على الماوى تبعه عشان
يرجع قد ما بده يكون في خطوره مش حيكون
خطوره قد اللي راح اللي راح كان صعب صعب
جدا فوق فوق ما تتصوروا خيال البشر كله
موت بن ادمين تقطعوا وجيرانك تفتوا كل
الدنيا تقطعت ما ضلش نفسيتنا تعبت الاولاد
تعقدوا الان بع لهذه الم بدي اقعد على
الردم من دون لا ميه ولا كهربا ولا حاجه
بدي اتنفس وبس هكذا هو المشهد اذا هنا في
هذه المنطقه منطقه ابراج الشيخ زايد وايضا
منطقه القريه البدويه هنا في بيت لاهيا
الاهالي بداوا يعودوا للحياه يوما بعد يوم
بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال بالكامل من هذه
المناطق رغم قساوه الحياه ورغم عدم توفر
اي امكانيات للاستمرار في الحياه الا انهم
اصروا على العوده
وعمل خيمه فوق هذا الدمار للاستقرار في
هذه المنطقه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه